[Musique]
acteur central des solidarités sur le
territoire le département de La Réunion
a institué depuis 2022 les forums
territorialisés de l'action sociale et
de l'insertion après trois éditions
réussi à Sainte-Suzanne braspanon et
trois bassins c'est un 4e Forum qui
s'est tenu ce mardi 28 mars sur le site
de Miel Vert à la Plaine des cavres en
partenariat avec la commune du Tampon
une matinée destinée à faire connaître
au public du tampon et de l'entre-deux
les dispositifs d'accompagnement vers
l'insertion des différents partenaires
de l'événement on accueille le premier
forum territorial du TAS sud-est et donc
c'est une très belle manifestation on a
en partenariat avec le Pôle emploi et
tous les institutions sociales la cape
les CCAS
tous les organismes de formation
les caravanes du département qui
présentent aussi les tous les tous les
actions tous les
ou la population se questionne donc nous
pouvons des réponses ce jour-là en tout
cas et donc très belle participation des
partenaires
du monde de l'emploi et de l'insertion
ces rencontres permettront justement de
d'inciter les gens en tout cas de les
faire connaître un peu les dispositifs
existants et et aussi aller vers c'est
aussi la la démarche du département ce
premier forum de l'action sociale et de
l'insertion du Tasse sud-est cette
organisée autour des différents
opérateurs institutionnels et
associatifs
œuvrant en faveur de l'accès à l'emploi
en fait les politiques d'insertion elles
sont foisonnantes il y a beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de beaucoup de
partenaires qui sont très actifs
notamment sur ce territoire du tampon
la mairie du tampon Pôle emploi la
Mission Locale organise avec la cassure
aussi organise régulièrement des des une
prestations à l'échelle des quartiers
sur l'insertion et le département FEDER
un petit peu toutes ces énergies pour le
public le public bénéficiaire de RSA le
public en recherche d'emploi le public
qui est déjà en emploient et qui a
peut-être envie de changer enfin tous
les publics qui sont en quête de
construire et de réussir un projet
d'insertion en parcourant les différents
stands et notamment ceux du département
le public a pu bénéficier d'informations
et de conseils concernant leurs droits
et les outils mis à leur disposition
grâce à la mobilisation des travailleurs
sociaux de la collectivité sur ces
forums les gens sont persuadés souvent
en venant un forum sur l'insertion qu'il
trouveront un emploi une fois qu'ils
auront fait le tour des stands mais en
fait ce sont on va dire des des moyens
supplémentaires des outils qu'on leur
apport pour avoir une connaissance
globale et plus grande des différentes
associations des différentes formations
ou des différents services qui
pourraient leur apporter des réponses
dans le cadre de leur propre insertion
donc ça leur apporte une plus grande
connaissance des dispositifs tels que
vous le voyez il y a des stands ils
peuvent aller directement à la rencontre
des professionnels poser des questions
et c'est tout à fait porteur beaucoup de
personnes ont besoin de de d'avoir le
maximum d'informations pour pouvoir ce
moment-là se poser et construire un
projet que soit d'un projet de vie ou un
projet d'insiation sociale professionnel
dans le fait que c'est un nombre de
partenaires soit sur place et puissent
apporter directement l'information dans
un environnement ou il y a une certaine
dynamique ça ça permet à certaines
personnes de trouver des idées ou des
idées ou de se dire je peux à ce
moment-là aller partenaire pour m'aider
à mettre en place une action d'insertion
c'est l'essentiel en tout cas un premier
forum pour le Tasse Sud-Est qui ne sera
certainement pas le dernier un deuxième
rendez-vous sera donné en fin d'année
2023 cette fois pour les publics de
Saint-Joseph et de Saint-Philippe
[Musique]